top star demi lovato kicked off for a
new tour with a heartfelt message she
invited survivors of the florida school
shooting on stage last night with her
and she asked fans he'll provide mental
health support to the parkland community
Lovato has been a mental health advocate
ever since she was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder back in 2010 Mariah
viel was at last night's concert in San
Diego and only on CBS this morning
she spoke to Lovato about her mission
behind her music
[Music]
Demi Lovato hit a personal note in front
of more than 7,000 fans at the debut
night of her tell me you love me tour
opening up about her own struggles with
depression and addiction
I want to share my journey with people
and my story so that it can open
people's minds and see that there's
nothing wrong with you just because you
have a mental illness the
grammy-nominated singer songwriter has
battled bipolar disorder for eight years
Mike Beier was instrumental in her
recovery I will forever be in debt to
heaven for coming into my life and
providing me with a place that was safe
and believing in me now business
partners they used the concert tours to
inspire others suffering from mental
illness to seek help a lot of dummies
music and allows for healing and it's
how do you turn sadness or just a tragic
situation into inspiration and
empowerment moved by the images of the
floor to school shooting Lovato
personally reached out to some of the
students on social media concerned about
their mental health after living through
the tragedy seeing something that
disturbing is just painful to watch and
my heart goes out to them On February 14
one of the worst mass shootings in
American history took place these
students were in the school that day she
invited survivors to her concert last
night to share their stories there has
been talk about obviously wanting to use
this shooting for gun reform but you
think this is an opportunity to talk
about mental health it has nothing to do
with politics it's about healing and it
was how can we help these students heal
from what they've been through these
students that came here today and shared
their stories are so incredibly brave
and courageous and they really are
warriors in my eyes
[Music]
while she continues her own journey of
healing the pop star says she's
committed to fighting this stigma
attached to mental illness one
performance at a time for CBS this
morning media vol San Diego
[Music]